lara j'ai une petite surprise pour vous
puisque par amour il ya une personne qui
vous a laissé un message
regarde regarder mais bonsoir mon amour
puisque est tellement pauvre mentorat
tous la rage est une petite question à
te poser mon amour de ma vie est ce que
tu crois qu'un jour on arrivera à dîner
ensemble
moi je t'attends moi en tout cas je
profite de ce petit moment pour te dire
combien je t'aime et un grand salut à
tout le monde dans la salle
ciao ciao franchement gabriel
exceptionnel je me reprenne là parce que
ça va mal il apparaît dans une pièce
qu'ils aient les papillons on est ce ça
fait sept ans quand même que je suis
marré magnifique franchement je l'admets
je lui gelé qui fait merveille
j'avais une meuf là j'ai dû faire un
truc bien à un moment donné dans ma vie
pour mériter un être paraître alors il
vous a posé une question qu'on vous
n'arrivez même pas dit non c'est plus
compliqué en ce moment c'est vrai je
travaille pas mal j'ai vrai j'ai
beaucoup ça fait bientôt dix neuf jours
que je suis pas rentrer à la maison du
tout donc c'est vrai qu'on est là en ce
moment à montréal comme on voit il fait
encore blog où sa déchirure ou encore
blanc est trop mignon et romy lemm
diable embrasse très fort après et
gabriel 6 mars avait dîné ensemble et
frère ou chez pour moi fait plaisir
et comment tu as préféré lara mon plat
préféré se serait ce serait un risotto
crevé un risotto saviez vous avez la
casse nous quand on excuse moi tu as le
riz d'ailleurs avec les trucs là les
elfes et non une risotto aux crevettes
ah ouais ben vous avez des chances et un
bon c'est vrai mais la mauvaise si vous
voulez m'inviter à la maison avec les
gabonais va écouter y a pas que moi je
voulais leur exploitation officiellement
aussi simple vous êtes officiellement
invité à manger à kazan en ce cas à
montréal comme vous voulez alors oui ça
coûte un pied de pensée pour elle sur
billetreduc la voir ce qu'il ya là parce
que bon ça m'arrange pas de ces
conneries